good afternoon I'd like to introduce you
to a few people who've been important in
my life this is my grandad filip mosz
era a first-generation American who
retired from the Navy is the chief
warrant officer after more than 30 years
of service standing next to my granddad
in this photo is my dad filip mosz era
he enlisted in the Navy during the
Vietnam War and third from 1971 to 1973
and he guess who's next this is me 35
years ago my name is also filip mosz era
and not surprisingly i grew up
associating service with a uniform and
so is a young man in suit in public
service i joined the military when i was
18 and spent more than a decade on
active duty as a Navy pilot but the most
enduring lesson of my time in the Navy
is that public service is not about what
you wear but about what you do and so
I'd like to talk with you today about
public service as a private individual
in 2004 out of station here in
California just over the mountains in
the Central Valley in a small town
called l'amour I remember driving to my
car on the way to base one morning and
passing a large billboard on the side of
the road that I hadn't noticed before
there was a picture of a young girl on
it sitting all alone in the photo she
seemed so sad and helpless was almost as
if she was staring right back at me the
message on the Billboard was simple it
said speak up for a child now as I would
come to find out that phrase speak up
for a child is the slogan of the
national nonprofit organization called
Court Appointed Special Advocates or
casa for short Casa volunteers are
appointed by judges fabricate for the
best interest of abused and neglected
children and to help them find safe
permanent homes
that message speak up for a child move
me that morning for a couple reasons
first and perhaps naively I couldn't
imagine that there were children in my
community who are being mistreated and
who didn't have a voice second my wife
misty was seven months pregnant with our
daughter Madame as a soon-to-be father I
wanted to help other children find the
same love and stability I would
eventually become a casa volunteer one
of my most vivid memories is working on
the case of a young girl with special
needs she was so bright and energetic
and so young at that point that she
couldn't quite pronounced my name Phil
so it came out as feel fe e oh she's in
a safe home now the result not just of
my voice but if a chorus of voices
speaking up for this young child you see
I worked alongside a talented nonprofit
director a dedicated social worker and
an incredible foster mother all of whom
were serving in their own way and not
one of them more uniform now for many of
you in this room this comes as no big
surprise if you've discovered the
rewards of public service I'm not asking
you to start I'm asking you to never
stop but for those of you like me that
have ever wondered how you can make a
difference without putting on a uniform
or working for the government or joining
a social enterprise I can tell you you
don't have to give up your chosen career
to serve you see public service isn't
the uniform you wear or your job title
or the industry you work in public
service is the measure you give of
yourself now I'd like to tell you that
my own service was solely the result of
a personal sense of duty but that
wouldn't be the whole story you see
serving also brought me in a men sense
of personal satisfaction of fulfillment
something that's actually very hard to
describe so instead I'd like to share
with you some more concrete examples
how serving can help you develop skills
and talents you never knew you had in
the military some very patient flight
instructors taught me to fly it remember
to land a plane on the deck of an
aircraft carrier an amazing experience
actually I'd like to qualify that it was
an amazing experience during the day at
night it was just scary as a child
advocate I got to stand up in a
courtroom and practice my persuasive
skills in front of a judge an incredible
opportunity and now as a volunteer Menlo
Park I'm getting an inside view of local
government as I work here at Stanford on
a certificate in public management so
you see service isn't all about giving
in fact it's a pretty balanced equation
you get to practice your private sector
skills in a public sector or nonprofit
environment making you a more versatile
well-rounded leader and you'll get to
connect with a network of other
professionals who are giving back in
2012 alone one in four adults in the
United States nearly 65 million people
volunteered their time in a variety of
different types of organizations from
civic to religious educational and it's
not just retirees and teenagers 35 to 44
year olds were the most likely to give
their time with higher rates of
volunteering among individuals with
higher levels of education now i
remember a call to service i've heard
not too long ago see before i came to
the GSB i spent two years just across
campus at Stanford Law School yes I will
be spending four years here at Stanford
instead of just two as a side note one
of the unexpected benefits of a joint
degree is that it's given me some
credibility with my daughter Madeleine
who's now in fourth grade as we sit
around the kitchen table doing homework
I can remind her that I'm in the 19th
grade
but back on that first day of law school
orientation sitting in a lecture hall
not unlike this classroom professor
George Fisher talked to the incoming
class about Professional Responsibility
lawyers receive special training that
gives them a unique ability to serve
others knowing but an attorney can
provide the advice or representation
that is needed by so many who can't
afford or don't have access to legal
services and so professor Fisher said
regardless of the kind of lawyer you
become make a commitment always have at
least one pro bono case but I can't help
but think the broader message resonates
here as well you see access to justice
isn't the only problem we face just as
we need lawyers to help the unserved and
underserved we need leaders to address
the problems facing our communities and
our country it doesn't matter if you're
a banker investor consultant analyst or
manager an organization out there could
benefit from your expertise and skills
as future graduates of the GSB as alumni
of our nation's business schools as
successful professionals in the private
sector we too have unique ability to
serve others there are so many different
opportunities and levels of commitment
from volunteering with a nonprofit
organization or civic association to
serving on a school board or City
Council but I understand that for many
of you the hard part isn't deciding what
you're passionate about or what
expertise you have to offer the hard
part is matching your skills with a
worthy cause so I'd like to recommend a
resource taproot is a national nonprofit
founded here in San Francisco in 2001
that makes a business talent available
to organizations working to improve
society in the bay area alone they've
matched thousands of professionals with
nonprofits that need help and areas like
strategy marketing and finance if you're
unsure about where you can best use your
skills for the public good
taproot can help now I will always be
grateful for the opportunity to have
served my country in uniform it was one
of the most rewarding experiences in my
life but I'm equally as hardened to know
that I can continue to serve even though
I no longer wear the uniform of a US
service member I still want to give back
I want to set an example for my daughter
and I have faith in the collective power
of private citizens doing public good so
I invite you to join me not by
abandoning your career but by
incorporating public service into it
think about the amazing talent you have
to offer think about the personal
fulfillment and professional growth
you'll get now imagine what the world
would look like if we all did thank you